this is what I asked you to start with
and what I asked you to grab right now
what I'm seeing a lot of as I walk
around is something a bit like this okay
now let's consider this okay now
literally I've seen that with very few
markings on vampire because you're not
sure what to mark on there I can see a
few problems with this graph and let's
try and unpack it okay the first problem
is what what is this what is that what
what do we define these axes to be this
is my time axis this is my displacement
axis right the time axis there T equals
zero sorry x equals zero what it
represents is the origin where did we
say the origin was it's the ground right
check the very least I've got parts on
this graph that don't exist
namely this part part exists in addition
at least this polygraph can't exist
because for the same reason but there's
another polygraph that also kind exists
right I'm trying to put forward this
graph as a reflection of what is
happening through the ball right what's
time zero what does that represent the
initial condition where it starts right
now in this situation what is happening
before time zero you got a couple of
choices you can either say nothing right
because I'm just considering here or
alternatively you can say it's just
there at what meter above the ground
right so if I really wanted this graph
this displacement time graph to
represent what the ball was doing really
I should have something like this should
really write because it's just well I
don't know maybe maybe something like
this because okay the point is you know
even if that is what the graph is doing
if that's what the board is doing I'm
not really interested in that all I'm
really interested in is this which is
the plot that I can analyze and apply
some calculus to okay so therefore what
I should say is let's just take that
part
but instead let's just put some
restrictions on it okay so whatever
whatever that is right I'm going to be
restricting my time domain from not to
whatever that is and I don't know what
it is yes okay now not only do I not
know where that is but I also don't know
where this is right at the moment on my
graph it looks like it's about two
meters now I know you know you probably
look at me and think yeah probably can't
live but I can tell you I can throw a
ball higher than two meters in the air
okay so I mean this is a problem I need
to fix this up I need to know where
where this is and I need to know where
this is so how do we do that you've got
tons of different ways to do it okay so
for instance let's take a one at a time
let's work out let's look at what this
guy is now you've got lots of ways to do
this you can fit okay I want to know
where the stationary point is thankfully
for you you don't need to differentiate
the sky because you already have the
derivative right so you can come back up
to here which is the same as seen where
is the ball not moving so you can you
can solve this guy okay so you can say
when the velocity is zero and we'll
solve our velocity equation okay see you
got this
yeah so doing it all in one sweep I'm
gonna get 15 on 9.8 so now 0.5
thereabout okay so that's what that's
telling me that's about 1.5 or something
like that okay approximately right now I
actually wasn't interested in where it
was in terms of time I'm interested in
how high did the ball go so how do I get
there I'm gonna take this value this and
I'm gonna put it into my displacement
equation okay so one of the things that
is sort of like the extra leap between
you might feel like applications of
calculus to the physical world it's just
it's just differentiate again
integrating stuff I've known before
right but one of the things that's some
chicky this is why I call it
that's wrong and should say [ __ ]
equations sorry
one of the things that's routinely
present in these kinds of questions is
that you always have multiple equations
sometimes you have got two objects so
you might have six equations or
something crazy like that okay so you
have to be careful about how they
interact with each other I want to take
this time and stick it into my
displacement equation so let's do that
okay what am I gonna get okay so I'm
gonna get a decimal out for this it'll
be a bit gross but at least I'll know
what ballpark I'm in right so by the way
the way I recommend that you do this
it's probably worth um reminding you is
that when you get to this point and
you've got whatever that number is let's
do it
when you've got 75 on 49s or my
calculator says or 1.53 well you've got
that there rather than typing that in
repeatedly just store it as a variable
and you calculate us so if you couldn't
remember how to do that you want to go
shift the button which says recall it
has store above it so there's the recall
button but there's Store bubble which is
actually what you want and then you pick
a letter right so for example on that
pick a which is above the above the
negative sign so store that to a and
what the display it'll say it's a into a
so now you can use that 15 on that point
8 wherever you like okay so now I can
just stick it into here
okay so what do we get what value do you
get check it against what I've got let's
do let's do two Jessel faces shall we
anyone got an answer to 0.5 okay yeah
it's to one decimal place so I'm getting
two point four seven nine five nine and
so on okay so that's approximately equal
to twelve point four eight meters does
that mesh with reality does that make
sense I think it's pretty reasonable I
think I can throw a ball 12 meters in
the yeah I think I can throw it further
than Tommy is in here actually so that's
reasonable that's okay
so immediately we know now this graph is
pretty bogus right if that's one beat up
then my stationary point should be way
up here off the board on my scale anyway
okay so maybe what you should have done
when you were graph E is realize that
you need this piece of information in
order to get your scale right okay so
instead of going here first maybe do
that roughly so you know what features
you try to work out and then do this so
you actually can work out this scale
what was the other piece of information
I was after all I wanted to know where
he hit the ground
right sir I want to know this value here
so what am I gonna have to solve to get
that which equations I want displacement
equals zero don't I okay so I'm gonna
take the displacement creature and
obviously I'm gonna have to use the
quadratic formula so let's do that it's
a quadratic in T so that's why I've got
T equals and I'll go okay what do we got
that negative 15 plus or minus the
square root of 225 minus 4 lots of
negative 1/9 so far so good all over 2
lots of negative 4.9 okay now
immediately at this point I have the
advantage I suppose this is a benefit
from having graph this okay
see how I start here right I started at
one
so I have to know that one of my one of
the roots right has to be for negative T
so I can automatically exclude that I
don't I haven't evaluated any of this at
all but I already know it's going to be
over here okay so straight away I can
say I can ignore this value I'll show
you as I do it let's go fifteen it's
actually gonna be this one twenty five
plus I can exclude one of the answers
immediately right because the other one
will be negative right when I sorry
exclude the answer that is negative so I
would say that you time is positive
actually well Taikan could zero so zero
and positive but excluding one the
reason why I included the negative is
because because there's a bigger down
bottom right so I actually want this one
the plus plus plus
alright so there you go get your
calculator out again don't forget your
brackets okay I've got a value and
someone who got one that they can check
against both
yep good so let me let me get all the
decimal points three point one two sinks
four and so on
yep okay now again before I do anything
does that make sense is if since well it
sure is a central value it's a bad
double what you expected here which we
got by a completely different way by the
way it does look about right it's not
it's not exactly double though isn't
because we started a meter off the boat
but it sports stop getting this so this
is seconds and this was meters okay so
the kinds of questions you could pose
off this are for instance well how long
is it traveling through the air there
you go there's an air time right and we
need it in order to actually graph it
with a follow-up question you might ask
is well how far as the board travel in
total how would you work that out how
far is the ball traveled in total you
have a couple of alternatives okay I'm
going to give you one and then I'm gonna
let you think about the other one on you
earned for a minute okay because we've
gone through all the effort of graphing
this number one and because it's a
fairly simple shape number two I think
your best option is to look at this
thing actually get the double right it
was 12 something and then say look there
are two parts to the journey right it
goes up and it goes down right so
therefore all you need to do is work out
that distance and add it to that
distance that's all that's the total
distance right
I mean any fancy calculus for that we
said that that was about twelve so sorry
that was about twelve so therefore that
must be about eleven this is the actual
tonal distance about twelve so you're
expecting to get in the twenty three
bomber ballpark right you'll obviously
have some we'd decimals flying around in
there
Oh point nine four nine five something
like that okay but you can work out the
exact odds on okay now that's not the
only way you could work out the total
distance how else could you do it hmm
now I'm gonna let you have a go at that
I've already told you what you want to
expect in terms of the number right how
would you go about doing it by area
under the curve I'll let you have a go
at that now